[Musique]
soir les enfants notre cher nounours est
très content ce soir arrive à aller
promener son amie juliette a pas trop
écoutez moi bien j'aime beaucoup
juliette à qui est un très gentil dhibou
mais je n'aime pas la promener je ne
suis pas le new
mountain
[Musique]
view
c'est bien c'est beau ce mois où c'est
le grand nettoyage
c'est un nettoyage forcément nous on a
des ennuis tu sais allons que se
passe-t-il
avec ses parents il avait besoin de lui
pour conduire dada est pour nous un
plaisir il nous a laissés
trop gentil tu parles heureusement il va
revenir bientôt juliet à elle est
terrible depuis qu'il est parti aux
longs
[Musique]
aux pauvres juliette à elle a du chagrin
que cornichons soit parti
sans aucun doute où est elle cette
chasse aux pauvres juilletà je vais la
chercher
j'ai eu tort
non elle n'est pas dans la cuisine
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est presque 4
juliette a au moins joli que fais tu là
mais voyons tu as du chagrin tu pleures
mais corniche on va revenir et c'est
alan vient avec nounours je vais
installer sur ton arbre tu sera beaucoup
mieux qu'ici
alors mais non ça va je viens te pleure
plus ça va mieux il fallait la console u
ne savais pas que j'avais du chagrin
pour vos julietta on croyait que c'était
caprices et va revenir aux cornichons
[Musique]
c'est une excellente idée mais à présent
juliette as tu dors tu prends ton bah tu
es sage et surtout tu ne te plains
promis
[Musique]
une annonce ni pau ne nuise pas
à nîmes gard ce
bonne nuit les petits
à deux mois
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors nounours tu as promener julietta
nos patrons la pauvrette est triste
parce que cornichons est parti mais il
va revenir la chercher
tant mieux allons en route bonne nuit
les petits faites votre toilette il
avait voulu dans n'oubliez pas embrasser
bien fort parent est fait pour
oh
[Musique]